sopra
come potete vedere sono in compagnia di
ludovico pagare e oggi parliamo di
tipologie di ragazze single
buona visione ci vediamo altri ma mai
sto pensando che non ti fidanzi anche tu
cosa facciamo un po lucida 4 è taylor
del tuo video mi avessero tutto questo
la devi fidanzarsi io sto bene da sola
va bene io non ho bisogno di nessuno per
essere completa io mi completo da sola
ma c'è un nuovo tipo che presenta roma
quando è scaduto enna nanna
ma come già mamma liu che tua mamma
certo
ciao ti darei lo definì scegliamo
reazione 16 chi preferisce numero 20 nel
giardino che rivali sella al suo cavallo
bianco e mi porge la mano dicendo nissan
leaf amore mio ti porto a palazzo a
conoscere il re mio padre reggiana la
mente forse anziane amore
lo percepisco nell'aria che arriverà
arriverà e sono a magical mistery
finalismo ecco mi divido casa basta del
genoa alla porta facendo il sushi molto
facile da qui lo devo al mio dalle
camera saranno da portinaio e adesso si
sta dirigendo ore 12 presso la palestra
non sovraimpressa file scaricati
chiamato la facciamo a cacciarlo chiara
non esiste solo in riunioni tra venti
minuti e valeri chiamare dopo che ti
devo dire cioè ma ti rendi conto
poi ci chiedono perché non sapere alzate
capo 24 anni per il figlio mai vista
fino al mio lavoro è allora qualcosa che
tutta formoso ma non troppo bello
stretto e vito comunque pettino quello
che la verve e la forma di cuore
comunque di perline dinos o svarowsky
poi il velo a lungo livello di perla di
queste parole come il mio vestito da
sposa è già tutto organizzato la wedding
planners sa già quello che deve fare e
lo sposo dove lo troviamo ma mignon
detto la chiromante mi ha detto che lo
troverò in troppi o meno sei mesi quindi
ho già mi sono davanti
e già tutto resta tuttora invitata tra
l'altro si sentì l'aria sì anche lui e
io no ma ancora io lo voto ma sono
passati ormai non basta beh allora alla
prova stima intanto mio numero ce l'hai
ciao belli
[Applauso]
ciao amore sono appena uscita da casa di
giuliano ma tornano a ieri sera abbiamo
fatto le brave siamo stati a casa
così tra vizi di scrive die non lo sa
nessuno ma se tu sei sempre più avanzate
che sono sì non ci abita abbiamo
riscontrato vi è qualche ardino quando
dietro aspetti fidati di me così va bene
che su questo si ma tutto anche se ne
vadano in tema verso quelle cose che
iniziano tutto bene fuoco di paglia ma
ma lui poi lo starà già mettendo le cose
meglio
purtroppo io spero tantissimo speriamo
che non sia piaciuto fare sapere con un
commento qui sotto
a quale di queste tipologie di single
appartenete e non avete fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino a casa infezione e
riduce anche su tutti gli altri ti ho
già rifiutato anche l'analisi bene ci
vediamo al prossimo video e come tutti
amici paese
a ruota noi ci vediamo al prossimo video
e chissà se ci saranno altri video
insieme in futuro un bacione
ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]